y responsable de asegurar la pensión a múltiples generaciones,
es un tema muy importante cómo gestionar el riesgo climático.
Recientemente analizamos nuestra cartera global,
cómo se alinea con el Acuerdo de París.
Fue diagnosticado,
nuestra cartera está en camino a más de tres grados.
Lejos de los objetivos del Acuerdo de París.
Nuestra cartera no solo es considerable
sino también una de las más diversificadas del mundo.
Eso significa que el mundo está en ese camino.
Estoy cansado de escuchar el mismo comentario repetidamente
de nuestra cartera de empresas y, obviamente, de profesionales de inversión:
"Somos realistas".
Lo siento, pero ser "realista" ya no es una opción.
Somos conscientes de la responsabilidad como mayor tenedor de activos del mundo
para inspirar cambios en el mercado de capitales.
Nos comprometeremos activamente con todos los actores en el mercado de capitales
para mover la aguja.
Espero poder participar en este diálogo crucial con todos Uds.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
CF: Estoy segura de que todos Uds. saben que durante los últimos 12 a 18 meses,
lo realmente nuevo, poderoso y emocionante
son las voces asombrosas de tantos jóvenes,
millones de jóvenes que andan por las calles,
con ira, indignación, desesperación,
y que nos piden que hagamos lo nuestro.
Y se han inspirado en Greta Thunberg
y en muchos otros jóvenes fantásticos
en casi todos los países del mundo.
Y hoy, estamos encantados de tener a cuatro jóvenes activistas
que vienen a sumarse hoy.
(Aplausos)
(Ovación)
Alexandria Villaseñor: Este viernes,
cumpliré 52 semanas de huelga climática.
Es todo un año.
Durante ese tiempo,
encontré que mucha gente no sabe sobre el cambio climático
ni qué tan grave es la crisis climática.
Entonces fundé Earth Uprising International
para enseñar a los jóvenes sobre el cambio climático,
porque cuando conocen la ciencia y los impactos,
quieren emprender acción.
Ser activista significa hacer que ocurra el cambio.
Jamie Margolin: Me convertí en activista climática
porque mi vida depende de eso.
Me estoy postulando a las universidades en este momento,
tratando de planificar mi futuro.
No habrá nada que esperar
si no tomamos medidas urgentes para detener la crisis climática ahora.
Comencé el movimiento de justicia climática juvenil Zero Hour en 2017,
porque esta es la hora cero para actuar sobre el cambio climático.
No tenemos más tiempo.
Me quedó claro
que nuestros líderes no iban a tomar medidas reales
a menos que la gente se pusiera de pie y lo exigiera,
así que hicimos exactamente eso.
Natalie Sweet: Me hice activista por la justicia climática
porque si no brego por los derechos de las personas de hoy,
y por las personas del futuro,
¿quién lo hará?
Xiye Bastida: me hice activista por la justicia climática
al darme cuenta de que la crisis climática impacta más a las comunidades marginadas,
incluyendo mi ciudad en México.
Hago huelga con Fridays for Future
todos los viernes,
porque en nuestro movimiento no se trata de ganar impulso
sino de encender el cambio cultural.
Pero el hecho de que miles de estudiantes estén en huelga por el clima
significa que ya estamos implementando justicia climática
en cada aspecto de nuestras vidas,
algo que ya está redefiniendo el mundo.
JM: En el transcurso de nuestras vidas,
hemos visto la Tierra deteriorarse a velocidad rápida
y a grupos de personas traumatizados y desplazados
por una cantidad cada vez mayor de desastres naturales.
En 2030 tendré 28 años.
AV: Tendré 24 años.
XB: Yo tendré 27.
NS: Yo 26.
Queremos poder entregar el planeta a nuestros hijos
y a los hijos de nuestros hijos,
así como muchos de Uds. han podido hacer.
AV: Entonces, a menos que todos,
gobiernos, empresas, escuelas, científicos y ciudadanos,
se comprometan juntos a revertir el daño que hemos causado,
será demasiado tarde.
XB: No solo les pedimos que cuiden nuestro futuro,
también les estamos pidiendo que cuiden nuestro pasado.
Los pueblos indígenas han estado cuidando la Tierra durante miles de años,
por eso la filosofía indígena es crucial
al implementar acciones climáticas.
JM: esta crisis climática puede parecer imposible de arreglar.
Pero no lo es.
Y no puede ser imposible
porque el fracaso simplemente no es una opción.
Fracasar implica perder todo lo que amamos
y todo lo que importa.
Muchos ya estamos trabajando para salvar el futuro de nuestro mundo,
pero la solución no puede quedar solo en manos de la próxima generación.
Es una carga demasiado pesada como para ponerla solo en hombros de los jóvenes.
Es hora de que todos pongamos manos a la obra
y hagamos lo que esté a nuestro alcance antes de que sea demasiado tarde.
¿Están con nosotros?
Público: Sí.
(Aplausos y ovación)
(Aplausos)
CA: Gracias. Gracias, gracias.
Y luego, por supuesto,
los narradores del mundo tienen un papel crucial que desempeñar,
quienes tienen influencia en plataformas de redes sociales.
Cada uno de los siguientes ha expresado entusiasmo
en ser parte de este proyecto.
Nos han prestado sus nombres y su apoyo.
Tenemos algunos de ellos aquí hoy.
Muchas gracias por estar aquí.
Escuchemos a uno de ellos, en realidad.
Jimmy Kimmel: Hola, soy Jimmy Kimmel,
y me pidieron que explique por qué me apasiona el cambio climático.
Y la razón por la que me apasiona el cambio climático
es la misma por la que quienes se están ahogando se apasionan por los socorristas.
Me importa este planeta porque vivo en él.
No quiero mudarme a Marte,
Marte parece terrible.
Quiero que mis hijos y sus hijos puedan vivir en la Tierra,
con aire que respirar y agua que beber.
Por eso me importa el cambio climático.
Y también, porque estoy enamorado de Leonardo DiCaprio.
(Aplausos)
CF: Y con toda esta gente congregada,
tenemos la oportunidad de explorar un nuevo espacio de posibilidades
en soluciones de trabajo conjunto,
que permitan desafiarse mutuamente
e inspirarse unos a otros.
Entonces, en octubre del próximo año,
estaremos invitando a unas mil personas más o menos
de diferentes circunscripciones a reunirse en Bergen, Noruega,
para alinearse en respuestas específicas a nuestras cinco grandes preguntas.
CA: Ciertamente será un evento épico.
Pero aún más significativo de lo que pasa en Noruega
es lo que ocurre en otras partes del mundo.
Porque en el último día de esa conferencia,
planeamos una activación importante de nuestra comunidad global TEDx.
TEDx permite iniciativas para organizar eventos locales,
y ahora hay 4000 de dichos eventos cada año.
Son así.
Tienen lugar en más de 200 países,
y generan más de mil millones de visitas al año en YouTube.
Esperamos ver eventos en cientos de ciudades.
Conectaremos a nuestros organizadores de TEDx
con alcaldes comprometidos con un futuro limpio para sus ciudades.
Esta es la clave.
Es esta conexión entre los poderosos,
que por lo general se adueñan de la conversación,
y millones de personas en el mundo.
Gracias al clima de época del último año o par de años,
de repente, algo puede surgir aquí,
porque hay suficiente masa crítica.
Si podemos darle a las personas visibilidad mutua,
conexión mutua,
soñemos un poco,
dense permiso unos a otros para soñar.
CF: Entonces nuestro objetivo aquí es construir conexiones
con y entre las organizaciones que trabajan en temas del clima.
Por ejemplo,
Solutions Project es una iniciativa maravillosa
fundada por Mark Ruffalo y Don Cheadle.
Y escuchemos a algunos de los líderes a los que han apoyado.
CA: Bienvenidas, están en vivo.
(Risas)
(Video) Wahleah Johns: Hola, mi nombre es Wahleah Johns.
Estoy con Native Renewables,
y estamos trabajando para proporcionar energía solar a tribus
de todo el mundo.
Tenemos más de 15 000 familias nativas americanas
que no tienen acceso a la electricidad,
trabajamos para llevar energía solar y baterías a estas familias
de Estados Unidos
que no tienen acceso a la electricidad.
Y se encuentran en mi reserva,
la Nación Navajo.
Anna Lappé: Hola a todos.
Soy Anna Lappé con Real Food Media,
y trabajamos para resaltar las historias de agricultores y ganaderos
como solución clave a la crisis climática.
El sistema alimentario mundial hoy es un gran contribuyente a esta crisis,
pero no tiene que ser así.
Vemos a los agricultores y ganaderos
en la vanguardia de ser parte de la solución a la crisis.
Tratamos de compartir historias de los millones de agricultores
desde Andhra Pradesh, en India, hasta las tierras altas de Oaxaca
que usan agricultura regenerativa para crear un suelo sano y rico en carbono,
cultivar buena comida
y fomentar el tipo de comunidades resilientes que necesitamos.
Rahwa Ghirmatzion: Hola, soy Rahwa, desde PUSH Buffalo
donde todos los días, los residentes visualizamos, planificamos y diseñamos
un barrio equitativo, holístico y sagrado,
desde donde estoy llamando, la Escuela 77,
un edificio escolar renovado
con el primer conjunto solar comunitario 100 % asequible
del estado de Nueva York,
instalado por residentes locales.
También ofrece 30 apartamentos asequibles para personas mayores
y una mezcla de espacios intergeneracionales
que sirven como centros comunitarios,
donde practicamos nuevas estrategias de economía
hacia un planeta habitable.
CF: Gracias.
CA: Bravo.
(Aplausos)
CA: Es genial.
CF: Como ven, es una cuestión de todos.
De las ciudades,
de las organizaciones de base,
pero también, por supuesto, de los negocios.
Y por eso invitamos a todas las empresas,
subrayo "todas",
a sumarse a esta iniciativa,
a comprometerse con sus empleados para proteger mejor el planeta
y su futuro, al mismo tiempo.
A principios del año que viene, compartiremos un juego de herramientas
que puede guiar a las empresas
a moverse rápidamente hacia objetivos con base científica,
que los lleve luego a emisión neta cero
para 2050 a más tardar.
CA: Entonces piensen en esto,
a nivel personal,
muchas personas se sienten impotentes ante este tema.
Pero si formaras equipo con otros dentro de la empresa,
te sorprendería ver cuánto poder realmente tienes.
Casi todas las emisiones provienen de una empresa en algún lugar del planeta.
Y la cuestión es que muchos CEOs hoy
ansían poder ayudar a resolver el problema.
Acabamos de escuchar esta mañana de Anand Mahindra,
quien dirige el mayor grupo empresarial de India,
que él personalmente está comprometido en este tema
y quiere ser parte de este viaje con nosotros,
es partidario de Countdown.
Los CEO podrán moverse mucho más rápido
si hay un grupo de empleados que piensen ideas, que los apoyen,
para mantener esa suerte de sentido de urgencia sobre el tema.
Nuestro sitio web ayudará a conectar con colegas dentro de tu empresa
y darte orientación sobre preguntas inteligentes para hacer,
iniciativas para sugerir,
porque si se persuade a las empresas a hacer lo correcto,
de repente, este problema parece tener solución.
CF: Todos estos esfuerzos contribuyen a un día fantástico:
Sábado 10 de octubre de 2020,
es decir, "10/10/2020", fácil de recordar,
día de esta reunión fantástica en todo el mundo.
Y esperamos tener, para entonces,
emocionantes noticias del informe de las soluciones muy específicas
con las que naciones, ciudades, empresas, ciudadanos,
en realidad ya estarán colaborando para entonces.
Es un día al que cada ciudadano del planeta
está invitado a participar.
Tu único boleto de entrada es ser ciudadano del planeta.
CA: Es clave para el éxito del evento que esto suceda a escala.
Queremos que sea fácil para todos y cada uno
conocer la iniciativa y desempeñar un papel activo en ella.
¿Pero cómo hacer eso?
Ya saben, el mundo es un lugar ruidoso.
Digo, la plataforma de TED puede ayudar un poco, tal vez,
pero hay una plataforma de contenido mucho más grande por ahí.
Se llama YouTube.
Y estamos encantados de trabajar con ellos en este esfuerzo.
Estaremos invitando a muchos de sus principales creadores
a ser parte de Countdown.
Colectivamente, podrían alcanzar una audiencia de muchos millones.
De hecho, conozcamos a uno de ellos,
Dr. Joe Hanson de "Hot Mess",
una nueva serie web sobre el impacto del cambio climático en todos nosotros.
(Video) Mi nombre es Joe Hanson,
y soy un educador de YouTube.
Y pueden contar conmigo.
Trabajo con los científicos del mañana, inventores y líderes,
y merecen saber la verdad de lo que dice la ciencia,
para que puedan ayudarnos a inventar un futuro mejor para todos.
CA: Imagina eso multiplicado por muchos más,
es muy, muy emocionante, sinceramente.
CF: Y por supuesto, si se trata de correr la voz,
cada uno de los presentes en esta sala en realidad puede desempeñar su papel.
Entonces, si tienen alguna forma de llegar a alguien
a quien le preocupe la construcción de un futuro mejor,
y deberíamos ser todos,
por favor, invítenlos a sumarse a Countdown.
CA: Hay una carta más bajo la manga.
Estamos emocionados de revelar una campaña mediática global.
Esta es una campaña con una diferencia.
Así como explotó TEDx
al permitirle crecer como fenómeno de base,
esta campaña está diseñada para ser cooptada en todas partes del planeta.
Si tienes una empresa de carteleras,
o un canal de TV, o un estudio de radio,
o un sitio web,
o una cuenta de redes sociales,
los invitamos a todos a tomar las imágenes que están a punto de ver
y a esparcirlas a lo ancho y lo largo.
Nuestro sitio web lo hará fácil.
En realidad planeamos traducirlos a muchos idiomas
cortesía de nuestro ejército voluntario de más de 20 000 traductores en el mundo.
Algunos de ellos están con nosotros aquí.
Si eres un traductor de TED, ¿saludarías, por favor?
CF: Ahí vamos.
(Aplausos)
CA: Su trabajo lleva ideas poderosas a cada rincón del planeta.
Estamos muy orgullosos de Uds., muy agradecidos.
Entonces esta campaña está diseñada para llamar la atención
y comunicar, sí, la urgencia
pero también un poquito de esperanza.
Creemos que esa combinación podría ser lo necesario para impulsar la acción.
Nos encantaría que nos cuenten qué piensan al respecto.
CF: Ahora mismo.
[Elige tu futuro.]
(Aplausos)
[Convierte el miedo en acción. Súmate a la cuenta regresiva.]
[La acción inspira acción.
Súmate a la cuenta regresiva. La Tierra te lo agradecerá.]
(Aplausos)
[10/10/2020 Día del Destino del Clima. Están invitados.]
CF: Recuerden la fecha.
[Destrucción masiva. No es problema. (Si la evitamos)]
(Aplausos)
[Asteroide gigante viene hacia nosotros. El enemigo común que nos puede unir.]
[Nos encantan los desastres naturales de todos modos - dijo nadie nunca.
Entonces, ¿por qué los estamos causando?]
(Aplausos)
[Relájate, no hay nada que puedas hacer sobre el clima.
A menos que trabajes para una empresa. O vivas en una ciudad.
O tengasun teléfono. O un cerebro.]
[Causa de la muerte: Apatía. Pero hay un antídoto.]
(Aplausos)
[Deja de cag*rlo todo.
La inacción en el clima es obscena. Podemos solucionar esto.]
CA: ¿Demasiado?
CF: No, no es demasiado, sí, adelante.
(Aplausos)
[¿Has emprendido alguna acción últimamente?
Esta es tu oportunidad. Ayuda a cambiar el rumbo del clima.]
(Risas)
CA: No me gustó esta, pero mi equipo, ya saben.
CF: Al parecer, hay muchos a quienes les gusta.
(Risas)
[Nos damos por vencidos. Sinceramente, TED.
Difundir ideas no es suficiente. Es hora de actuar. ¿Te sumas?]
CA: Esto es, desafortunadamente, más cierto de lo que conocen.
[Algunas cosas importan más que la política partidista.
Ven a luchar contra el enemigo que nos puede unir.]
(Aplausos)
[Detén el agotamiento.
tu empresa puede ayudar a salvar el planeta.]
[Dale más al planeta de lo que tomas de él.
Súmate a la cuenta regresiva.]
[Desesperación, más esperanza.
Podemos evitar la catástrofe climática si tomamos medidas urgentes ahora.]
CA: Es todo.
(Aplausos y ovación)
CF: Para cerrar el círculo,
nos gustaría traer a alguien muy especial.
(Video) Hola, soy Claire O'Neill.
Soy la presidenta de la COP para la Conferencia de Partes del próximo año,
conversaciones anuales de la ONU sobre cambio climático, que será en el RU,
y esperamos darles la bienvenida allí.
Pero ahora mismo estoy en España, en Madrid,
en la COP25, este evento anual
donde enviamos negociadores y activistas de todo el mundo
para ver qué podemos hacer para reducir las emisiones de CO2.
Pero el problema es que las emisiones aumentan, no disminuyen.
Y siento que 2020 es el año de la acción,
el año en que tenemos que dejar de hablar
y tenemos que empezar a actuar.
Y no solo aquí, en estos centros de conferencias,
sino todos.
Por eso el valor del proceso de TED,
el valor de lo que todos estamos haciendo juntos
reside en extender las conversaciones
y las soluciones desde el interior de este espacio
hacia todos.
Deseo con ansias trabajar con el grupo de TED
durante el próximo año.
2020, para mí, será el año más importante para la acción climática,
y todos vamos a lograrlo juntos.
(Aplausos)
CF: Bien, amigos, ya casi finalizamos
pero quisiera sumar unos fragmentos especiales.
Primero, la palabra de uno de las muchas grandes mentes
que nos acompañarán en este viaje.
Un mensaje del gran escritor, historiador y futurista
Yuval Harari.
Yuval Harari: El cambio climático es una cuestión de inequidad.
Inequidad entre los ricos, que son los principales responsables,
y los pobres, que sufrirán más.
Inequidad entre nosotros, Homo sapiens,
que controlamos este planeta,
y los otros animales, que son nuestras víctimas indefensas.
Inequidad entre los científicos,
que buscan minuciosamente la verdad,
y los engañadores profesionales,
quien difunden falsedades con el clic de un botón.
El cambio climático implica tomar una decisión.
¿Qué tipo de planeta queremos habitar?
¿Qué tipo de humanos queremos ser?
Una elección entre avaricia y compasión,
entre descuido y responsabilidad,
entre cerrar los ojos a la verdad
y abrir los corazones al mundo.
El cambio climático es una crisis,
pero para los humanos, una crisis siempre es también una oportunidad.
Si tomamos las decisiones correctas en los próximos años,
no solo podemos salvar el ecosistema,
sino también podemos crear un mundo más justo
y transformarnos en mejores personas.
(Aplausos)
CF: ¿No es ese un marco conceptual poderoso de lo que tenemos por delante?
Sinceramente, creo que es algo trágico
que el poder de la transformación que tenemos por delante
se vea gravemente disminuido por quienes querrían politizar el tema
y separarlo en política partidista.
No puede ser un problema partidista,
no se puede politizar este tema.
Afortunadamente, hay quienes están trabajando en contra de eso.
Hoy tenemos a una de esas personas,
una increíblemente valiente científica del clima,
una cristiana comprometida,
que ha estado trabajando en este tema
con conservadores y con comunidades religiosas y espirituales durante años,
con un valor increíble.
Katharine Hayhoe.
(Aplausos)
Katherine Hayhoe: Cuando alguien dice cambio climático, a menudo pensamos
"Es solo un problema ambiental.
De personas que abrazan árboles o científicos que se preocupan por eso,
o quizá de personas de la izquierda del espectro político".
Pero la realidad es que lo sepamos o no,
ya nos importa el cambio climático, sin importar quiénes somos.
¿Por qué?
Porque el cambio climático afecta todo lo que ya nos importa hoy.
Afecta nuestra salud,
afecta la comida que comemos,
el agua que bebemos, el aire que respiramos.
El cambio climático afecta la economía y la seguridad nacional.
Me importa un clima que cambia porque es, como lo llaman los militares,
un multiplicador de amenazas.
Toma temas como la pobreza y el hambre,
la enfermedad, la falta de acceso a agua potable,
incluso la inestabilidad política,
y los exacerba o amplifica.
Por eso, para ocuparnos de un clima que cambia,
no debemos ser determinado tipo de persona.
Un termómetro no es azul ni rojo,
progresista o conservador,
nos da el mismo número sin importar cómo votemos.
Y a todos nos afecta el impacto de un clima que cambia.
Por eso, para ocuparnos de un clima que cambia,
solo debemos cumplir una premisa:
ser humano y vivir en el planeta Tierra.
Todos cumplimos la premisa.
(Aplausos)
CF: Y finalmente,
el hombre que tan poderosamente puso este problema a la vista de todos
hace unos años
y ha continuado incansablemente trabajando en ese tema desde entonces.
El único y muy singular, Al Gore.
(Aplausos)
(Video) Al Gore: Gracias.
Muchas gracias, Christiana,
y gracias por tu destacado liderazgo,
y gracias a Chris Anderson y a toda la comunidad de TED,
YouTube y todos los demás que se suman
a esta fantástica iniciativa.
Solo tengo tres mensajes.
Número uno, esta crisis es increíblemente urgente.
Justo ayer, los científicos nos dieron el informe
de que las emisiones siguen en aumento.
Cada día, ponemos 150 millones de toneladas
de polución provocada por el hombre por el calentamiento global
en la delgada capa de atmósfera que rodea a nuestro planeta.
La cantidad acumulada ahora atrapa tanta energía extra cada día
como si lanzásemos 500 000 bombas atómicas de primera generación
y explotasen cada día.
Y las consecuencias son cada vez más claras...
todo lo que la madre naturaleza nos dice,
los incendios, el aumento del nivel del mar,
las inundaciones, los flujos de lodo,
y la pérdida de especies vivientes.
Pero el segundo mensaje que tengo es que la esperanza es muy real.
De hecho, tenemos las soluciones a disposición para nosotros.
Desafortunadamente, es cierto en este momento,
que la crisis empeora más rápido de lo que estamos movilizando estas soluciones.
Pero las energías renovables, los vehículos eléctricos,
las baterías, la agricultura regenerativa,
la fabricación circular,
y todas estas otras soluciones están ganando impulso.
El difunto economista Rudi Dornbusch,
al articular lo que se conoce como la ley de Dornbusch, decía:
"Las cosas tardan más en ocurrir de lo que uno cree que tardarán.
Pero luego, ocurren mucho más rápido de lo que uno pensaba que ocurrirían".
Podemos acelerar el ritmo.
Estamos ganando impulso
y pronto estaremos ganando sobre la crisis
Pero es esencial que todos se sumen:
de cualquier índole política,
de cualquier índole ideológica,
de cualquier nacionalidad,
debe borrarse toda división para que todos, la humanidad,
podamos unirnos.
Y para terminar, solo diría que para quien duda
que como seres humanos
tenemos la capacidad de estar a la altura de la circunstancia,
cuando todo está en juego
recuerden que la voluntad política es en sí un recurso renovable.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
CA: Muchas gracias.
Muchas gracias Al por el liderazgo en este tema
durante tantos años.
Nada de esto sería posible
sin una lista extraordinaria de socios que crece rápidamente.
Me gustaría reconocerlos.
(Aplausos)
Si estás viendo
y crees que tu organización debería ser parte de esto,
puedes ayudar de alguna manera,
súmate, envíame un correo a chris@ted.com.
Esto va a involucrar a todos.
Bien, antes de las preguntas y respuestas,
quiero hacerte una pregunta en lo personal, Christiana.
¿Qué piensas realmente?
(Risas)
No, has estado en muchas iniciativas.
¿Tiene esta iniciativa una oportunidad?
CF: Bueno, antes que nada,
estamos en un punto en el que todo cuenta.
Todo cuenta.
Y esto me entusiasma mucho,
porque me ha resultado muy doloroso ver cómo en los últimos 12 a 18 meses
debido a una respuesta trágicamente insuficiente
hemos tenido que hacer frente al cambio climático,
y cómo el clima de época ha cambiado desde donde estábamos en París,
que era bastante positivo y optimista,
hasta ahora, desesperación, impotencia, ira.
Eso es lo que hay afuera vagando por las calles.
Y no los culpo, tengo los mismos sentimientos.
Pero la idea es que
tenemos que poder transformar eso para marcar la diferencia.
Y creo que esta iniciativa tiene el potencial para lograrlo,
que es darle a cada persona que se siente impotente,
darle una herramienta para hacer algo.
Algunos contribuirán con pequeños esfuerzos,
otros contribuirán con grandes esfuerzos,
depende de cuál sea su área de influencia.
Y para quienes se sienten enojados y desesperados,
bueno, darles también una oportunidad para canalizar esa energía
-- una energía muy poderosa --
hacia las soluciones.
Y finalmente, algo muy emocionante sobre esto
es la escala, Chris, ¿cierto?
Es decir, mira esos socios que van a estar ahí.
Hemos intentado muchas, muchas cosas para darle escala.
Pero creo que esta es la iniciativa más prometedora que he visto,
poder multiplicar las personas,
multiplicar esfuerzos y soluciones.
Y velocidad.
Porque si hay algo en lo que no podemos fallar
es abordar el cambio climático,
pero no solo eso,
sino hacerlo de manera oportuna.
CA: Gracias, eso es elocuente.
Y gracias a Uds.
Es todo.
(Aplausos)
Bien, tenemos muchos miembros de los principales medios del mundo aquí.
Haremos una sesión de preguntas y respuestas,
probablemente deberían tener prioridad en las preguntas.
En caso de silencio mortal, otra persona puede hacer una pregunta.
Si hay algún miembro de los medios,
por favor, no dude en levantar la mano y le alcanzaremos un micrófono,
y haremos lo mejor que podamos.
Rachel Crane: Hola, Rachel Crane de CNN.
Mi pregunta para ti tiene que ver con una acción más específica
que saldrá de Countdown.
Escuchamos mucho hoy
cómo esto se está movilizando el mundo sobre este tema,
sacando a la gente de sus silos, a las empresas de sus silos,
pero tengo curiosidad por saber, píntame un cuadro para nosotros,
qué acción saldrá de esta iniciativa,
qué aspecto tendría esa acción.
Estoy segura de que todo está en fases preliminares,
no pediremos precisiones sobre esto.
CA: Hay un proceso intenso entre ahora y octubre,
donde trataremos de participar
con los mejores del mundo pensando en el clima
en torno a esas cinco grandes áreas.
Esperamos tener allí múltiples propuestas
que colectivamente aborden una parte sustancial de estos problemas.
Algunos de ellos, puede haber alguno grande que domine.
Ya sabes, el transporte, por ejemplo.
¿Podríamos acelerar el final
del motor de combustión interna, de alguna manera?
¿Qué requeriría eso?
Ese sería un problema clásico hecho para este enfoque,
porque lo que los gobiernos deciden ahora
depende de lo que vean que ocurre en otro lugar.
¿Cambiarían las decisiones de los ejecutivos de las automotrices
si viesen a millones de personas en las redes sociales diciendo,
"¿Nunca compraré un motor de combustión"?
¿Cambiarían ante la señal del mercado de cientos de alcaldes que dijesen,
"Estamos creando una zona de carbono cero en nuestra ciudad,
y vamos a expandirla,
y lo haremos pronto"?
¿Las cambiaría un CEO visionario de una automotriz que asuma el riesgo
y venga y diga,
"Sabes cuando dijimos que íbamos a continuar esto hasta 2050,
no, podemos ver el mensaje en el muro,
queremos estar en el lado correcto de la historia,
lo haremos para 2030".
Pensamos que podría haber un camino hacia eso.
Entonces, en algunos de estos temas,
va a depender de enormes discusiones, de congregar a las personas,
de mostrarles, y en esto tú eres magistral,
es mostrar que otras personas no tienen las actitudes
que uno piensa que tienen.
En realidad están cambiando, será mejor que cambies.
Y así se eleva mutuamente el nivel de ambición de todos.
Y ese es un ciclo que ocurre,
y ya lo hemos visto ocurrir.
Y así, en cada uno de estos temas, eso es lo que estamos buscando.
Las cosas más grandes y audaces.
Soñamos más grande de lo que normalmente hacemos,
porque hay más gente en la mesa de la que normalmente hay,
es decir, millones de ciudadanos comprometidos en esto.
Ese es el proceso y mientras eso ocurre,
habrá muchos otros compromisos en empresas y ciudades del mundo.
Esperemos que todo se una de manera emocionante en octubre
y tengamos algo que celebrar.
Dominique Drakeford: Mi nombre es Dominique Drakeford
con MelaninASS, o redes sociales como forma de medios.
Para entender la correlación inherente
entre la acumulación de carbono en la atmósfera
y la explotación acumulativa
y la extracción, la economía extractivista,
que crea zonas de sacrificio para comunidades negras e indígenas,
cómo planeamos,
o cómo planean Uds. mitigar esos sistemas de opresión
como parte de sus estrategias dentro de esos cinco componentes diferentes,
para poder realmente empezar a reducir las emisiones?
CF: Si la transformación en nuestra economía y nuestra sociedad
no incluye eliminar la inequidad y abordar cuestiones de justicia social,
entonces no estamos haciendo nada.
Porque todas esas cosas se volverán en contra.
Por eso debemos poner manos a la obra sobre todo el paquete.
No es fácil, pero es completamente posible.
Y esa es una de las cosas que me entusiasman del cambio climático,
porque está al frente de esta transformación,
pero traerá aparejados muchos de los otros problemas
relegados a la falta de atención.
Traerá esos problemas al primer plano también.
La transformación tiene que ser una transformación integradora.
Ellen Maloney: Hola, Chris, hola, Christina.
Mi pregunta es, los esfuerzos individuales,
como deshacerse de pajitas de plástico o hacerse vegano,
¿marcan una diferencia
o son solo gotas simbólicas en el océano?
CF: Buena pregunta.
CA: Es una buena pregunta.
CF: Son totalmente importantes.
Absolutamente importantes.
Porque no es solo la pajita que uso.
Tiene que ver con que yo no use esa pajita,
y al ir al restaurante le diga a la camarera,
"Disculpe, no quiero una pajita de plástico, porque..."
y darle una pequeña lección,
entonces ella le dice al gerente, el gerente a la mesa directiva y dice,
"Disculpe, ¿podría explicarme eso?"
Luego repasas la lección.
Y antes de lo pensado,
tienes a ese restaurante y a los otros.
En realidad, la información es contagiosa.
Y querer hacer lo correcto también es contagioso.
Así que no lo veas como simplemente, ya sabes, "¿Qué es una pajita?
¿Estoy usando la pajita o no estoy usando bolsas de plástico?
Tengo mis bolsos a base de plantas para ir de compras", etc., etc.
Todo eso cuenta.
Cuenta para ti, en primer lugar,
porque es un recordatorio personal de quién eres y qué representas,
pero también es una herramienta muy importante
para educar a todos a tu alrededor.
CA: Correcto, y pienso que el núcleo de nuestra iniciativa es,
todo eso importa: lo que comes,
cómo te transportas, etc., importa mucho.
Pero las personas tienen otro poder
al que no tenemos muy en cuenta, quizás,
y pensamos que deberían considerar, los invitamos a reflexionar,
y es lo que pueden hacer como empleados
y lo que pueden hacer como ciudadanos.
Hay una reunión aquí,
donde al organizarse, al conectar con otros,
pensamos que hay una ruta directa para cambiar decisiones
que tendrá un impacto aún más grande en el problema.
Entonces sí, todo eso, pero más también.
(Risas)
CF: Hay una [pregunta] en línea, de un aula de niños.
CA: ¿De un aula de niños?
CF: "¿Qué pueden hacer los estudiantes?"
Sí, me encanta esa pregunta, Amo totalmente esa pregunta.
Primero que nada,
los viernes, 11 en punto, ir a la huelga.
Es decir, francamente, ¿sí?
(Aplausos)
Vayamos, vayamos.
Y esa presión tiene que mantenerse.
Me encanta que haya personas aquí
que han hecho huelga durante 52 semanas.
El problema con esto es, amigos,
esto no es un sprint, es una maratón.
Así que mejor prepárense para muchas más 52 semanas, ¿sí?
Y hagan que más personas participen,
porque esto no es fácil.
Si fuera fácil, lo habríamos hecho.
Este será un esfuerzo a largo plazo.
Pero es fantástico estar ahí en las calles,
se consigue mucha más atención de los medios,
de nosotros adultos estúpidos que no hemos hecho nuestro trabajo,
es fantástico.
Entonces, ya saben, hagan oír sus voces.
Además, en la escuela,
definitivamente pueden ir y mejorar...
La pregunta que acaban de hacerle a TED,
es la pregunta que todos los estudiantes deberían hacerle a su escuela:
"¿De dónde viene mi energía?"
Vayamos con eso, ¿sí?
Los estudiantes en colegios...
¿Cómo es posible que todavía tengamos colegios y universidades
que no tienen 100 % de energía limpia
y que no han cambiado su capital y su dotación
por una baja en carbono?
Es decir, es simplemente increíble.
(Aplausos)
Y finalmente, lo más importante que los jóvenes pueden hacer
es preguntarle a sus padres,
"¿Qué demonios estás haciendo por mi futuro?"
Porque aquí hay algo asombroso.
He hablado en... Estaba pensando cuántos...
Hablé con al menos tres, si no cuatro CEOs de la industria del petróleo y el gas.
He hablado con tres o cuatro principales inversores,
jefes de sus empresas de inversión,
que se me acercan, por lo general en privado,
y dicen, "Christiana, la razón por la que estoy cambiando lo que hago en mi negocio
es porque mi hija, o mi hijo,
me pregunta por la noche, '¿Qué demonios estás haciendo por mi futuro?'"
Esa es una pregunta muy poderosa,
y solo los jóvenes pueden hacer esa pregunta.
Usen esa herramienta...
pregúntenle a sus padres qué están haciendo por el futuro de Uds.
Disculpen el lenguaje que usé.
(Aplausos)
Jo Confino: Hola, soy Jo Confino, de HuffPost.
Christiana, una pregunta para ti,
cuál es una de las cosas que no salió mucho
y tiene que ver con las tradiciones espirituales
y el papel que juegan,
porque lo que estamos viendo
es que, en realidad, emerge la vieja sabiduría
en términos de interdependencia
y nada está separado de cualquier otra cosa.
¿Cuál es la tradición espiritual que podemos aportar a esto
eso marcará, también, una diferencia?
CF: Algo que creo muy poderoso sobre la comprensión,
ya sea que se trate de una persona espiritual
que hace meditación y mindfulness
o que se trate de una persona religiosa o no,
pienso que algo muy poderoso
sobre la comprensión espiritual de la presencia humana en esta tierra,
es entender que no estamos separados.
No es que "Allá está el planeta Tierra,
y luego aquí están los humanos".
Estamos totalmente interconectados con todas las demás especies
y con todos los demás seres vivos,
y hacer algo responsable por ellos,
es hacer algo responsable por nosotros.
Y viceversa.
Así que la interconexión
viene de las tradiciones espirituales,
pero no hay que ser religioso o espiritual para entender eso.
Ya saben, el hecho es que
cada gota de agua que bebemos proviene de la naturaleza.
Cada bocado de comida que comemos
proviene de la naturaleza.
Y tenemos que sanar esa conexión.
CA: Agradeceríamos el compromiso.
(Aplausos)
Kaley Roshitsh: Hola, Kaley Roshitsh de Women's Wear Daily.
Obviamente, la industria de la moda es responsable de gran parte
de la producción de carbono,
así que me preguntaba cuál es su perspectiva sobre el consumo consciente?
CA: El objetivo clave aquí es alinear, al mismo tiempo,
cambiar de opinión sobre lo que hacen las empresas,
lo que hacen los empleados, lo que hacen los consumidores.
Que todo eso ocurra al mismo tiempo es lo que puede lograr el cambio.
Ahora mismo, siempre es otra persona el problema.
"Nuestros inversores no permitirían que hagamos eso".
"No hay mercado para este producto que es mejor, más sostenible".
Por eso todo debe ocurrir al mismo tiempo.
Esa es nuestra esperanza.
El liderazgo en esto no lo tenemos nosotros,
son los empleados y CEOs y los equipos de liderazgo
que trabajan en esa industria.
Reúnanse, hagan que algo ocurra.
Y monten la ola del cambio de época que está ocurriendo...
va a funcionar desde el punto de vista comercial también.
CF: ¿Puedo reaccionar a eso también?
Porque durante años, y siglos,
hemos tenido una mentalidad como consumidores, de extraer y consumir.
Nuestro modo de vida,
la forma en que se crean empresas,
es extraer, usar, descartar, extraer, usar, descartar.
Es una simplificación, pero sinceramente, es tan simple como eso.
Y entender que ese extraer-descartar
ya no puede ser el caso, debe ser circular ahora,
tenemos que entrar en una economía circular
que use cada recurso que extraemos,
porque seguiremos extrayendo
y lo use no una vez, sino dos, tres, cuatro, cinco, 10 veces,
una y otra vez en círculos.
Esa es una economía circular.
Y tenemos que llegar a ese punto,
porque nos estamos quedando sin recursos para seguir extrayendo.
Jodi Xu Klein: Hola, mi nombre es Jodi Xu Klein,
del South China Morning Post, una publicación de Hong Kong, aquí en EE.UU.
Hemos estado informando sobre la guerra comercial por más de un año,
y en realidad vivimos en un mundo
donde los países se están desacoplando unos de otros.
¿Cómo superar esa tendencia y reunir a todos?
CA: No sabemos,
son problemas realmente desafiantes.
Lo que sí sabemos es que tenemos que traer a todos a la mesa
y dar la discusión.
Hay mucha gente en China,
incluyendo, en muchas ocasiones,
el gobierno chino ha dado pasos audaces
para abordar este problema.
Occidente puede aprender mucho de lo que pasa en China.
CF: Yo diría,
en un mundo en el que estamos viendo una ola de nacionalismo y populismo,
la forma de abordarlo en realidad es expandir
la amplitud del compromiso,
para no dejar que la responsabilidad de comprometerse con el clima
esté solo en manos del gobierno nacional.
Sí, tiene un papel importante,
pero también podemos disminuirlo
a un nivel diferente de compromiso que es cada ser humano.
Y una vez que entendemos que todos somos seres humanos
y que todos tenemos un futuro común,
no existe tal cosa como que todos estamos en un bote
y solo los más cercanos al hoyo del bote son los que se hundirán.
No.
O nos hundimos todos, o salimos a flote todos.
Justine Calma: Me llamo Justine Calma, de The Verge,
muchas gracias por esto.
Mi pregunta es sobre la huella de carbono de TED y YouTube.
La transmisión de video consume una gran cantidad de energía,
y siento curiosidad por lo que TED y YouTube
podrían hacer por reducir sus emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
en relación a eso.
CA: No puedo hablar por YouTube, obviamente.
Diré que, para citar una línea de George Monbiot,
todos somos hipócritas en este movimiento.
Si alguna vez has comprado algo
o usas ropa, o comes alimentos,
eres un hipócrita, estás creando emisiones.
Es parte de la vida.
Y creo que la perfección es...
Se corre el riesgo de que la perfección,
de una búsqueda excesiva de perfección y centrarse en eso
y el juicio que eso trae aparejado puede ralentizar a todos.
Queremos que esto sea una coalición de personas dispuestas que aceptan
que no son perfectas pero están dispuestas a actuar.
Todo este proceso ha provocado una gran conversación en TED
sobre cómo actuamos de manera más responsable,
y eso continuará.
Ciertamente, no vamos a dejar de transmitir videos.
En algún momento hay que echar las cuentas,
es darle al planeta más de lo que tomas de él,
Es la regla de oro en la que yo realmente creo.
Y si una idea, potenciada por un poco de electricidad
puede activarse en el cerebro de alguien,
apostaría por esa idea sobre el ahorro de electricidad.
Pero no hay perfección en esto.
Y definitivamente tenemos mucho para mejorar.
Vayamos aquí y luego de regreso.
Lane Florsheim: Hola, soy Lane Florsheim de The Wall Street Journal Magazine
y Chris, realmente me gustó lo que estabas diciendo
sobre la industria de la moda y lo que puede hacer para cambiar
y cómo requiere que empleados y CEOs se reúnan
porque quién entiende una industria mejor que las personas de la industria
y sus procesos e infraestructura,
pero me pregunto, ¿qué pasa con las empresas con enormes huellas,
y dos que me vienen a la mente primero son Amazon y Zara,
donde, según se sabe,
los trabajadores, los empleados allí no tienen mucho poder
y los CEOs no tienen mucho incentivo para cambiar en este momento.
¿Qué dirías acerca de ese tipo de empresas?
CA: Esto va a ser una conversación importante en el futuro
porque estamos en la posición irónica
en la que las personas que pueden hacer más para resolver este problema
son los infractores más grandes.
Entonces ¿qué hacemos?
¿Los hacemos parte de la conversación o no?
Yo digo que los hagamos parte de la conversación
siempre y cuando veamos un compromiso serio.
Por ejemplo, Amazon.
Jeff Bezos realmente ha escuchado lo que muchos de sus empleados han dicho:
la base de empleados ha sido muy vigorosa allí,
sobre la huella de carbono...
ha escuchado, se ha comprometido contigo y con los demás.
Y han anunciado, creo que es correcto decir anunciado,
CF: Sí, lo han hecho.
CA: ... una aceleración de su propio compromiso
para pasar, básicamente, a una pista de cero neto para 2040, si entendí bien.
Son compañías con miles, decenas de miles de camiones
y el embalaje y todo lo demás.
Así es como se resolverá este problema.
Por eso digo que invitamos a estos CEOs a ser parte de esto,
y los instamos a tomarlo en serio
e ir rápido y quizás incluso más rápido de lo que hoy es su zona de comodidad.
Pero creo que eso es lo que tenemos que hacer.
No difamar, denunciar,
antes de que al menos hayamos tenido una conversación seria al respecto,
"Ya es hora,
tus empleados quieren hacer esto,
tus clientes quieren hacer esto,
tus inversores cada vez más quieren hacer esto, hagamos esto".
Esa es nuestra esperanza.
CF: Y lo maravilloso de las empresas del tamaño de Amazon,
o Walmart cuando lo hicieron,
es que tienen un enorme efecto de goteo.
Porque cuando Jeff Bezos salió y dijo:
"Voy a hacer de Amazon neutral en carbono para 2040..."
El Acuerdo de París dice 2050,
por supuesto que quiere hacer algo mejor que eso,
por eso Amazon dice 2040.
Bien, vamos a mantenerlo en ello.
Ahora, lo sorprendente de eso
es que para que Amazon sea neutral en carbono para 2040,
tienen que trabajar con toda su cadena de suministro.
Tienen que trabajar con todas esas empresas
que les brindan bienes y servicios
para que estas sean neutrales en carbono lo antes posible.
Porque de lo contrario, no pueden cumplir su propio compromiso.
Las grandes empresas son un factor muy, muy clave e instrumental en esto,
porque no se trata solo de su huella de carbono,
sino de la huella incrustada que heredan en su cadena de suministro.
Y la transformación de eso es realmente enorme.
CA: Última pregunta.
Jackie Padilla: Mi nombre es Jackie de NowThis News,
todos los días trabajo con jóvenes activistas climáticos
como los que hemos escuchado hoy,
pero cuando hacemos historias sobre ellos,
ya saben, incluyendo a Greta Thunberg,
veo que enfrentan críticas feroces
y en gran parte, debido a la brecha generacional.
No sé si está familiarizado con la frase "OK Boomer"
pero parece que hay mucho de culpa o responsabilidad
que algunos buscan,
y en el otro extremo vemos una falta de instrucción
o simplemente ignorancia sobre el tema.
¿Cuál es su consejo para que los jóvenes puedan responder a esa crítica
para fomentar conversaciones constructivas?
CF: Quizá deberíamos preguntarles.
XB: Hola, gracias por tu pregunta.
CA: Ven aquí.
(Aplausos)
XB: Es cierto que cada vez enfrentamos más críticas,
y no es solo cuando hablamos con negadores climáticos
o cosas así,
sino también en las redes sociales.
Es tanto una herramienta para difundir información
y organizar nuestras huelgas
y sacar la información por ahí,
pero también una herramienta para quienes quieren quebrantarnos,
para atacarnos personalmente.
Pero la forma de mantener la resiliencia
es construir comunidad unos con otros,
cuando nos organizamos,
imitamos el mundo que queremos ver.
No hay jerarquía en nuestra organización,
todos trabajamos para el mismo objetivo de manera constructiva,
eligiendo nuestras pasiones para hacer que la huelga sea lo mejor posible.
Tenemos 300 000 personas en huelga en Nueva York,
organizamos un concierto completo,
la gente lo llamaba "Climchella", fue genial.
(Risas)
Pero la idea es que no nos va a detener.
La crítica no nos va a detener.
Y aunque sabemos que somos niños,
y no estamos aquí para contarles todas las soluciones
que ya existen,
vamos a hacerlo,
porque cada niño que se preocupa por la crisis climática
va a crecer para estudiar a través de una lente ambiental
y para cambiar el mundo a través de eso.
Así que estamos aquí para decirles
activistas climáticos que conozco no usen "OK Boomer",
porque bregamos por la cooperación intergeneracional.
Y creo que culpar y dividirnos
no nos va a llevar a ninguna parte,
por eso no lo usamos,
y no creo que deba usarse,
y realmente quiero agradecer a todos los que hacen algo,
porque la acción inspira la acción.
Y Uds. nos inspiran a nosotros,
y estamos contentos de inspirarlos a Uds. también.
(Ovación y aplausos)
(Aplausos)
CA: Guau.
CF: Ahí lo tienen.
(Aplausos y ovación)
(Aplausos)
CA: No hay mejor manera de terminar esto.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)